jury finding the former minneapolis
police officer guilty on all counts in
the death of george floyd
we do want to go back out now to michael
george who was at the top of our
coverage at this hour he's been
following this trial from minneapolis
for us
michael we saw earlier community members
outside the government center at the
george floyd square where he was killed
reacting with tears and hugs over this
guilty verdict
what are people sharing with you
yeah it's been a very emotional
afternoon here a lot of people breathing
a sigh of relief remember this is a
community
that has seen national guard troops on
the streets for weeks
and have been prepared for the
possibility that this verdict would end
with violence instead it's ending with
celebrations people embracing we can
hear the cars honking
even from where we are now a lot of
people really just taking in this moment
it's been a very peaceful night
and a lot of people celebrating what
they feel is a fair and just
verdict and michael we know that
chauvin's bail has now been revoked he
now awaits sentencing what happens next
well yes he's facing a maximum of 40
years behind bars and then
that's just for the second degree murder
charge he also has two other significant
charges
that could bring another 25 year
sentence for one of the charges 10 years
for the other sentence so
uh the sentencing is the next phase of
this trial in two months also we have to
remember that
there are three other officers who are
present with derrick shilvin who are
also facing charges
of aiding and abetting murder so that
trial will be upcoming as well
all right michael george in minneapolis
thank you so much for your time
have a good evening and thank you for
your coverage